bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
la situation financière du brésil
provoque un affaiblissement
quasi-générale des cotations sur les
places boursières dans le monde
inquiétude aux états unis première
grande crise politique ouverte pour la
commission européenne deux commissaires
l'espagnol marine et la dame edith
cresson sont mis en cause ce soir un
compromis semble possible avec le
parlement européen
la délinquance des mineurs est en
augmentation messieurs jospin
chevènement prévoit des mesures
répressives ce soir un document dans
journal histoire ordinaire d'un
adolescent multirécidiviste voleurs de
voitures invités de cette édition le
président du tribunal pour enfants de
bobigny jean pierre rosenberg rémission
du mauvais temps en france mais la nuit
dernière fut longue très longue pour des
automobilistes ile-de-france piégés par
la neige
un millier de spécialistes des allergies
réunis à paris première journée du
congrès consacré à l'allergie aux blacks
cette fois donc la crise est venue
d'amérique du sud du brésil où la
situation financière était devenu si
difficile sous la menace de sécession
économique de l'un des états du brésil
que le président de la banque centrale
de ce pays a préféré démissionner
entraînant par cascades un début de
débâcle boursière
et pourtant l'état de santé de
l'économie brésilienne semblait
s'améliorer
voyez le reportage de notre envoyé
spécial à sao paulo luc baziz 1 avec
daniel lévy
sao paulo capitale économique du brésil
aujourd'hui la fièvre est encore montée
d'un cran ici au coeur de la bovespa
premières bourses d'amérique latine le
président de la banque centrale du
brésil a donné sa démission
la monnaie le real a perdu près de 10%
de sa valeur
le marché s'est à nouveau mis à douter
de lui-même déjà en août dernier un
séisme avait fait chuter lundi ce
brésilien de plus de 40% après la crise
russe
les investisseurs avaient fait un
amalgame avec tous les pays émergents
même si le brésil bonne élève était
alors en pleine croissance
c'est à dire sur les 60 jours qui
couvrent août et septembre
les investisseurs étrangers ont retiré
du pays l'équivalent d'environ 160
milliards de francs conséquence les
coûts financiers pour certaines
entreprises brésiliennes sont devenues
insupportables
ici chaque labine fabricant de papier de
carton 800 salariés ont été licenciés
pour remettre le pays sur le bon chemin
le président de la république
brésilienne a promis du sang de la sueur
et des larmes
en fait des mesures d'austérité où
voisinent augmentations d'impôts et
réduction des dépenses publiques wap un
tacle est partie la crise est passée
mais pour les entreprises brésiliennes
une autre crise a ri elle est due à
l'augmentation des impôts décidée par le
gouvernement et aussi à l'envolée des
taux mises en place pour soutenir la
monnaie et éviter la fuite des capitaux
les brésiliens vont affronter le pire de
la crise en 1999 en attendant des jours
meilleurs les brésiliens se jette dans
les bras du tout à crédit qu'il s'agisse
de vêtements ou d'automobiles tout peut
se payer en plusieurs fois
même si certains dépensent plus et plus
vite que les autres les investisseurs
une fois encore hésitent à parier sur
les 160 millions d'habitants du brésil
ne sachant pas s'il viendra ou pas un
jour grossir la société de consommation
ce fut donc aujourd'hui une nouvelle
illustration de l'interdépendance des
économies mondiales à commencer par
celle des états unis particulièrement
lié aux pays latino américains mais sur
toutes les places boursières on aura
noté une baisse des cotations à paris
à la clôture le cac 40 est à - 3 46%
explications pascal golomer il a beau
invoquer des raisons familiales
gustavo franco n'a trompé personne se
met ont démissionné de son poste de
président de la banque centrale du
brésil
il a provoqué une belle panique sur tous
les marchés financiers du monde à
singapour d'abord qui clôturait en
baisse de 2% puis sur toutes les places
européennes -6 9% à madrid ou 1 4% à
francfort -3 % à londres -3 et demi pour
cent à paris partout on veut se
débarrasser des actions des sociétés
très engagé au brésil les banques
notamment car les investisseurs n'ont
plus confiance dans ce pays incapable
d'adopter un plan de réduction
budgétaire
ce plan qui conditionne le versement du
solde de l'aide promise par le fmi à
l'automne dernier 230 milliards de
francs
la bourse de new york à son tour ouvrait
en baisse cet après midi au même moment
à la maison blanche bill clinton
rappelait aux journalistes son souhait
de voir la crise brésilienne se résoudre
au plus vite
l'amérique latine est aujourd'hui le
marché en plus forte croissance pour les
entreprises américaines à strasbourg
tout au long de cette journée de
mercredi le président de la commission
européenne monsieur jacques santer a
menacé de démissionner la commission
européenne est en effet à la veille d'un
possible double vote de censure des
députés siégeant au parlement de
strasbourg
cette première grande crise politique de
l'exécutif européen est né de
révélations sur des fraudes présumées de
gestion notamment imputé au commissaire
espagnol monsieur manuel marine et à sa
collègue française madame edith cresson
explications arnaud boutet et je suis
prêt à prendre ma part de responsabilité
dans ce contexte
en mettant sa démission dans la balance
jacques santer a peut-être sauvé la
commission qu'il préside pour tenter
d'éviter la crise avec une partie des
députés du parlement européen
jacques santer accepte également le
principe d'un audit sur sa gestion
edith cresson un rapport la soupçonne de
fraude et de favoritisme au sein de la
commission
elle rejette les accusations contenues
dans ce document parle de cabale et
refuse de quitter son poste
comment pourquoi voulez-vous
démissionner afin de faire cesser cette
inimaginable la période des sacrifices
humains dans nos civilisations et est
terminée depuis longtemps et pourtant
rien n'est joué
demain les députés voteront pour
censurer la commission est peut être
exigé la démission d'edith cresson et
d'un autre commissaire
alors aujourd'hui c'était
l'effervescence les groupes négocier
dans les couloirs et les salles du
parlement nous sommes dans cette
situation très curieuse
soit nous nous des juges on nous nous
couchons en votant en ne votant pas la
censure soit nous votons la censure et à
ce moment là nous ouvrons une crise le
parlement européen doit prendre ses
responsabilités rappel ce soir jacques
santer traite jours après le lancement
de l'euro cette crise fait désordre et
pourrait laisser des traces et samarie
mono compromis pas compromis cents
surpassant soeur mais disons qu à
l'heure où nous parlons les différentes
formations politiques du parlement
européen se renier pour trouver un
compromis
il serait le suivre vote d'une
résolution dans laquelle ne figurait
plus la démission des deux commissaires
visé par les critiques et du cresson
manal marine deuxième étape
l'adoption d'une stratégie pour le vote
demain de la censure les deux
principales formations sont divisés tant
à gauche parti socialiste européen qu'à
droite le parti populaire européen
c'est tout simplement le reflet un petit
peu des divisions nationales de suspense
est total
deux remarques premièrement comme vous
le disiez les institutions européennes
traverse sa crise la plus grave depuis
l'élection au suffrage universel en 1979
du parlement européen deuxièmement le
président jacques santer a été choisi en
1995 par les différents pays membres
tout particulièrement les allemands les
britanniques
pourquoi de la shr été aujourd'hui y
aurait-il des arrière pensées politiques
après l'euphorie de l'euro et 626
députés ont donc voulu donner une leçon
de démocratie mais semble ne pas vouloir
aller jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire la
censure qui aurait eu pour conséquence
la démission de la commission
ils ont en effet difficile que la
majorité absolue et les deux tiers des
suffrages exprimés soit 1 de même il dit
les électeurs vont certainement être
troublé et l'exprimons dans six mois au
cours des prochaines des élections
européennes
ouais merci christian la délinquance des
mineurs fait l'objet depuis quelques
jours d'une série de déclarations de
messieurs chirac jospin et chevènement
les responsables politiques sont en
effet alerté par une augmentation de
plus de 11% du nombre de mineures mises
en cause dans des crimes et délits en
1998 on sur 100 de plus par rapport à
1990 ces mineurs interpellés représente
un peu plus du quart de la délinquance
constatée en france et chacun d'évoquer
des mesures plus répressives contre ces
jeunes qui commettent des actes de
violence voici un document document
rapportés par une équipe de france 2
avec joël bruandet france vaillant ce
reportage a été tourné à lille notre
équipe suivent est une brigade anti
criminalité
lorsque de manière inopinée un garçon de
14 ans a été arrêté depuis 9 heures du
soir trois policiers de la bac brigade
anticriminalité patrouillent dans les
rues de lille
il est 12h30 au pied d'un immeuble les
policiers repèrent une voiture suspecte
deux personnes vont être interpellé
il a dub a qu'un pas qu'a parfaite et
ouais alors pour le conducteur du
véhicule il s'agit d'un mineur de 14 ans
et le passager avant majeur de 18 ans a
reçu d' ali un vol de voiture sur deux
est commis par amy neuf dans la voiture
des policiers un dialogue s'improvise
avec le mineur et sa copine majeur c'est
pas méchant mais n'étant pas content il
a 14 ans 31 ans pierre frelot déjà et si
mineur non toi tu crois que l'excusé est
mineur savate à exonérer à vis des vols
de voitures sur les bobs est interpellé
tu rigoles tu penses à la rigolade dont
coupât aussi 32 fois qu'il est
interpellé par les par les filles qui
sont fous totalement une heure du matin
les deux adolescents arrivent au
commissariat central
ils savent maintenant qu'ils vont passer
la nuit en garde à vue
chaque année 7000 personnes se
retrouvent entre ses quatre murs 7000
personnes dont deux mineurs deux heures
plus tard l'officier de police
judiciaire arrive et signifier
officiellement le placement en garde à
vue en 2006 il les parents n'ont pas le
téléphone une patrouille se rend donc à
l'adresse indiquée
c'est ce que l'on appelle la vie à
famille une procédure obligatoire dans
le cas de mineurs il est 3 heures du
matin et personne ne répond dans les
locaux du commissariat l'audition du
jeune mineur a commencé fort des scores
pause
je suis mon calcul il faudra attendre 11
heures du matin pour que la maman
viennent chercher son fils au
commissariat
cette femme séparée de son mari vient
accomplir ce qui est devenu une triste
formalité il se calme pas au profit cela
venez-vous de nommer au niveau de
l'autorité parentale ça se passe comment
avec lui
tu en as assez dans la mare ou deux
jours de parole de la gamme de
chaussures
est ce que le fait d'être en garde à vue
ça fait réfléchir parce qu'on pense à
beaucoup de choses on aura le temps de
réfléchir
tu penses à quoi bah qu'est ce qu'ils
vont manger ce que j'ai déjà
et à ton avis qu'est ce qui va t'arriver
quand il va sortir
je suis quoi ils se privent pas
recommencer
pour ce jeune la solution c'est de ne
pas le renvoyer systématiquement dans
son quartier ça ça me paraît tout à fait
clair il faut pour ce type de
délinquants multirécidivistes qui je le
répète non sens en déshérence non plus
de règles sur lesquelles la société et
les parents etc n'ont pas non plus de
deux prises
il faut forcément l'éloigner de son
quartier
douze heures après son interpellation
l'adolescent est libéré en cas de délit
la loi ne permet pas aujourd'hui de
placer en détention provisoire
un mineur de moins de 16 ans dans sa
poche le garçon de 14 ans a glissé une
convocation chez le juge pour enfants
jean pierre à cette vieille bonsoir vous
présidez tribunal pour enfants de
bobigny où présidé l'association
nationale des communautés éducatives
donc vous connaissez tous à ce genre de
situation en l'impression qu'il se passe
rien donc c'est une sorte de petit
séjour et puis ensuite y repart
oui c'est difficile de commenter pour
moi comme magistrat une affaire qui est
en cours mais c'est l'impression que ça
donne et je pense qu'il nous manque des
choses il ya obligatoirement nous dit
que c'est un jeune qui a déjà commis
nombreux délits une 30 à une trentaine
il ya obligatoire un éducateur ou une
équipe éducative qui est en charge du
suivi de ce jeune ou et l on n'entend
pas parler ici
l'autorité parentale on peut aussi
s'interroger les parents sont pas
chaises deux à trois heures du matin
mais apparemment ils laissent leur
enfant de 11 ans sortir avec une jeune
fille de 18 ans 14 à 14 ans vide m'en
sortir avec une jeune fille le soir et
dans les voitures
on peut s'interroger et puis l'autre
chose que je veux dire c'est que c'est
une manière de réagir peut être la
justice mais il ya d'autres manières de
réagir par exemple cette affaire-là se
serait produite en seine saint denis je
crois que après sa garde à vue le jeune
aurait été déféré au tribunal le les
éducateurs du tribunal aurait fait le
point avec l'éducateur qui est en charge
de ce jeune les parents auraient été
convoqué la mère aurait été vu par le
procureur au parquet le procureur on
essaye de faire le point d'autres termes
il serait pas ressorti le soir avec une
convocation
on a osé mettre en oeuvre quelque chose
il risque quoi par exemple il ne s'est
pas mis risque dix huit 18 mois de
prison
il risque la moitié de ce que risque
majeur un majeur risque trois ans de
prison lui risque sur cette affaire-là
est clairement à ce qu'on dit un garçon
de 14 ans peut parfaitement elle est en
prison tout à fait il ya trois mille
huit cents
mineurs qui l'an dernier sont allés en
prison et jacques mon cabinet une jeune
fille qui a commis vol survole et qui
exécute une peine de 8 mois dont 4 mois
ferme pour vous c'est ce qu'on appelle
un sauvage en se pinçant c'est un gamin
qui est qu'elle est c'est à vau-l'eau
qui est en difficulté qui a le manque de
repères qui a une partie de famille il
n'est pas inscrit dans une bande
apparemment heavy autre chose il
comprend pas la gravité des actes qui
peut commettre donc il ya vraiment un
travail éducatif à faire peut-être
effectivement le retirer de son milieu
provisoirement mais il faut travailler
aussi les relations avec les parents
peut-être qu'il faut l'éloigner pour lui
faire vivre autre chose dû faire
comprendre qu'effectivement on peut
vivre autre chose que la nuit voler des
voitures
alors nous allons voir maintenant ce qui
existe déjà comme comme mesure comme
législation contre les mineurs
délinquants et une ordonnance de 1945 et
remaniée qui a été remanié multiples
reprises et qui prévoit donc bien
l'éloignement pour la seule année 97
près de trente mille jeunes sont passés
par les foyers de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse et pour les
délinquants les plus récalcitrants il
existe 13 dispositif éducatif renforcé
même système en place si l'on veut
l'améliorer nécessite évidemment de
l'argent supplémentaire commentaires
tirer curtet le texte date de 1945 mais
il a fait l'objet de nombreux
aménagements depuis cette date
sa philosophie est simple ils
privilégient l'éducatif avant les
mesures répressives
les possibilités sont larges il
yad'abord l'admonestation le simple
avertissement puis les travaux d'intérêt
général des travaux éducatifs
d'intégration ou de réparation suite à
des dégradations par exemple il est
ensuite l'éducation surveillée dans le
cadre d'un accord sous conditions passé
entre le juge et l'adolescent il est
alors prise en charge par une équipe un
indicateur le suivra toute la journée
une mesure qui peut s'accompagner d'un
éloignement à l'autre bout de la france
pour le sortir de son milieu il y ait
ensuite le placement en institution
or de son foyer donc ce sont des lieux
ouverts où l'adolescent est prise en
charge jusqu'à 18 ans les maisons de
correction ont été fermées en 77 leur
efficacité n'étaient pas probants mais
faute de moyens quatre à cinq mille de
ces décisions prises par des juges n'ont
pas été exécutés et puis il y à l'échec
la prison possible dès 13 ans même si
pour un délit c'est à dire pour un ou
plus
vol il ne peut y avoir de détention
provisoire dans ce cas il faut un
jugement pour être envoyé en prison
avant 16 ans sauf s'il en a commis un
crime un championnat nba
vous avez réagi assez vivement aux
déclarations des hommes politiques
monsieur chirac jospin où j'ai demandé
ans et de la surenchère car il existe
déjà tout un dispositif certain hervé
dit on n'a pas de mémoire
on n'a pas de mémoire n'a oublié que le
8 juin 1998 après un débat qui a duré un
an après les travaux du conseil
économique social la mission
parlementaire
animée par madame lazerges et monsieur
balduyck toute une série de travaux qui
ont été faits par les uns et les autres
le gouvernement à discuter à arbitrer ce
niveau la polémique les à l'époque entre
monsieur chevènement alain bigou les
décisions ont été prises décisions qui
sont intelligentes qui sont équilibrées
consiste à dire il faut pas se laisser
faire par les jeunes qui avaient des
délits il faut réagir intelligemment la
répression c'est beau c'est nécessaire
dans certains cas la prison c'est pas
une fin en soi il ya d'autres méthodes
il faut inventer par exemple les mesures
des baraques de réparation par exemple
les travaux l'intérêt général mais dans
le même temps le gouvernement est venu
d'iran conseil supérieur pendant conseil
de sécurité intérieure il faut mettre en
oeuvre une politique sociale il faut
mettre en place une politique familiale
une politique de citoyenneté il faut pas
se contenter de réprimer à court terme
il faut réfléchir à ce qui se passe pour
les quatre ou cinq ans qui viennent et
nous avons toujours comme magistrat
comme éducateur nous avons toujours que
ces mesures qui ont été décidées se
mettent en oeuvre il a dégagé une
impression qu'ils changent d'avis qu'ils
reviennent sous la pression d'une longe
manche ne changerai pas d'avis parce que
ce qui a été décidé au mois de juin est
équilibré intelligent je pense qu'il
faut décider de dégager enfin les moyens
qui sont nécessaires c'est pas seulement
un chèque qui est nécessaire il faut de
l'argent
mais il faut aussi trouver dans ce pays
les hommes et les femmes qui vont
partager un bout de route avec ses
gosses qui sont en grande difficulté
et si on ne mesure pas si on peut se
passer à l'heure actuelle risque d'avoir
d'autres problèmes demain alors ses
autres problèmes ça veut dire qu'ils
viennent dirait une génération des
enfants encore plus jeunes qui sont déjà
en danger de délinquance nous sommes
tous convaincus les plus hautes
instances là encore je me réfère au
conseil économique et social je me
réfère à beaucoup de militants a
beaucoup de professionnels j'ai discuté
à cette année encore avec le contrôleur
général de police dans mon département
nous savons des enfants que non
seulement 6 en septembre 8 ans sont en
grande difficulté actuellement
on les a repérés quand il était à la
crèche n'hésite à l'école maternelle
compte tenu de la crise que traverse
actuellement le service social scolaire
il ya personne pour s'occuper de ses
enfants si on ne fait rien vont à 10 12
13 ans et dans la rébellion contre les
adultes car ils ont subi l acquisition
des premiers
les premières acquisitions de lecture
ils ont été déjà en situation d'échec
ils n'ont pas de parents pour les
encadrer pour cent d'entre eux ils vont
commencer par ce qu'on appelle
d'incivilité agresser les adultes et on
le dit vont tomber la délinquance en
sachant que dans le quartier avec la
stratégie qui existe à l'heure actuelle
le business le trafic de drogue
il ya plein de gens qui vont les
récupérer comme étant les petites mains
de la délinquance et là on passe très
rapidement à la violence de rue donc on
a une génération qui est en difficulté
ceux qui n'ont pas d'espoir à l'heure
actuelle je rappellerai au passage que
s'il ya 22 % délinquance n'est commise
par les jeunes 78 % de la délinquance
est cueilli par les adultes alors pas de
racisme anti-jeune il faut leur rendre
la justice aussi à ces gosses quand pas
de perspectives n'ont pas d'avenir qui
sont condamnés la violence des rues mais
dans le même temps il faut savoir qu'une
autre génération qui se prépare et celle
là si on vient pas l'aider l'urgence il
y aura de très très gros problème merci
sur zenden est alors en parallèle de ce
qui se passe en france c'est en italie
que la classe politique s'interroge sur
une brusque montée de la criminalité
les débats portent sur la législation
actuelle les réponses à trouver face à
la délinquance des jeunes mais aussi
face à un accroissement de l'immigration
en italie commentaires hervé brusini
c'est le neuvième en neuf jours lui il
avait 33 ans assassiné par deux jeunes
tueurs
les autres victimes étaient vendeurs de
journaux consommateurs dans un bar
écoute couteaux des coûts de 7 65 et des
milanais qui se sentent abandonnés par
l'état
c'est la colère bien sûr la colère à
l'étranger veygoux clandestins j'insiste
bien là dessus ils sont libres d'agir et
de commettre des violences et nous nous
sentons en prison chine
et voilà l'ennemi désigné les albanais
les croates les sénégalais tous ces
noirs comme on dit là bas
l'exaspération est à son comble on
menace de s'armer de faire justice soi
même parce que faute de tranquillité on
perd patience alors sur ce plateau de
télévision face à l'urgence de la
criminalité
la plupart des autorités italiennes
étaient réunis hier soir juge ministre
opposants il agitait peu ou prou les
mêmes questions que se pose la société
française la reconquête hystérie soir un
contrôle de l'immigration
le renforcement de la loi l'aggravation
des peines en matière de trafic de
drogue
la semaine dernière le président du
conseil massimo d'alema présenter son
plan anti mafia des peines plus dures et
l'éradication définitive des parrains à
présent c'est le nord du pays qui subit
les assauts d'une violence quasi
quotidienne au moment où la classe
politique débat les citoyens attendent
des signes des gestes en silence un
lourd silence contre la violence à
l'école en france et des agressions dont
ils sont les victimes une centaine
d'enseignants venus de plusieurs lycées
et collèges d'ile-de-france en grève
manifestaient aujourd'hui devant le
ministère de l'éducation nationale pour
le ministre claude allègre des mesures
sévères et rapide pour répondre à ces
agressions seront prises très bientôt
incidents à ajaccio lors de la séance
solennelle de rentrée du tribunal
d'ajaccio le bâtonnier de ce tribunal a
critiqué très vivement les autorités
gouvernementales et le préfet de corse
sur les modalités de l'application de
l'état de droit dans l'île aussitôt le
préfet bernard bonnet a quitté le
tribunal
cet incident survient la veille de
l'arrivée en corse du miz l'intérieur
jean pierre chevènement commenté olivier
caroff audience solennelle au tribunal
d'ajaccio
le rendez-vous annuel des plus hautes
autorités de l'île au premier rang le
préfet de corse bernard bonnet en face
le bâtonnier des avocats lui a réservé
une surprise
l'opinion publique est une fille des
rues là on ne la lui fait pas elle a
déjà compris qu'en tentant de
culpabiliser de la culpabiliser c'est
l'état que l'on veut blanchir
elle le sait d'autant mieux qu'on lui a
fait déjà le coup en fait de discours
pour la nouvelle année un réquisitoire
qu'on me l'ait mais d'autres états
nations et c'est l'incident le préfet
quitte la salle seuls les avocats
applaudiront les magistrats eux
resteront imperturbable demain le
ministre de l'intérieur jean pierre
chevènement arrive dans l'île en visite
officielle hier la veuve du préfet de
corse claude erignac assassiné en
février 98 s'interrogeait dans un
communiqué l agence france presse sur le
remue ménage entre policiers et juges
dans l' enquête sur cet assassinat
cette polémique agace manifestement de
mise l'intérieur reportage michèle fines
et jérôme soûlard sait depuis longtemps
une rumeur c'est devenu une certitude
ces deux hommes se détestent pourtant
ils travaillent ensemble ils sont co
saisi dans l'enquêté sur l'assassinât du
préfet erignac
d'un côté le très médiatique jean louis
bruguière pionniers de l'antiterrorisme
de l'autre gilberte il un juge venue de
nancy depuis son arrivée en 1995 au sein
du pool antiterroriste l'ambiance n'est
pas au beau fixe
c'est une fuite au niveau de l' enquête
qui a tout déclenché il y a quinze jours
le canard enchaîné et l'est républicain
publie les extraits d'un rapport de
police le parquet de paris ouvre
immédiatement une information judiciaire
recel de violation du secret de
l'instruction
en clair un juge est chargé de trouver
d'où vient la fuite au sein du pool
antiterroriste l'heure est aux soupçons
la sphère revient sur la place publique
hier la famille erignac a fini par
demander dans un communiqué que les
juges ou blizzard querelle il faut que
l'on travaille ensemble se fasse
confiance et il est clair que si les
magistrats ne travaille pas main dans la
main entre d'abord puis ensuite les
services de police on n'aboutira jamais
je crois qu'il faut que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités chacun reprenne son
calme et la famille ne demande que cela
à la sortie du conseil des ministres ce
matin jean pierre chevènement était
aussi cette polémique est regrettable il
y a à l'intérieur et un seul c'est
l'intérêt de lanquais et de son
aboutissement
tout le reste est subalterne voire
nuisible jean louis bruguière gilberte
il est laurence le vert le troisième
juge chargé de l'enquêté
tous ont été entendus au palais de
justice un magistrat recherche toujours
l'auteur de la fuite
l'arrestation de l'un des auteurs du
hold up et de la prise d'otages de tain
l'hermitage arrestation à givors dans la
banlieue sud de lyon cet après midi que
tu es mauvais temps et circulation
routière ou ferroviaire les choses se
sont améliorées aujourd'hui la nuit
dernière enfants en ile de france fut
longue très longue très très longue pour
des milliers d'automobilistes piégés sur
les routes autoroutes parisienne récit
de cette nuit blanche dans les
bourrasques de neige nièce gardère noir
douars et jean françois meunier et
france veilhan des centaines de camions
ont pas pour immobiliser la situation
était encore bloqué ce matin sur
l'autoroute a10 sans compter le froid et
le verglas qui avait rendu la route
dangereuse
alors dans ces conditions normales que
le réveil soit un peu difficile
c'est clair si blanche que la neige ça
c'est sûr
des fais les valises en recouverte avec
les habits qu'on avait
l'allongé saussez jariel tout avait
pourtant bien commencé vers 18 heures
avec les premiers flocons sur paris de
bien belles images qui se sont vite
transformé en cauchemar
à 19 heures lorsque les parisiens sont
du travail
les deux ou trois centimètres de neige
trouvé en moins d'une heure sème la
panique
ouais c'est l'enfer dès que vous voulez
sur la place là quand même c'est pas
grave j'en ai marre ça fait 3 heures en
voiture là on n'avance pas
mais la galère c'est sur les grands axes
quelle fut la pire sur l'a10 comme sur
la nationale 118
les automobilistes sont restés pendant
des heures coincés dans leurs véhicules
je suis enceinte de sept mois et je ne
dis pas un petit peu là je commence un
petit peu à m'impatienter je suis parti
à 18 heures mais ulysse et il est donc 3
heures du matin dans la nuit on a compté
jusqu'à 300 km de bouchons sur
l'ensemble de l'ile-de-france
les secours ont dû parfois intervenir
pour un peu de réconfort et calmer les
impatients car après la tente
la colère gagne les engins de la dde qui
sont passés quand même passé ils sont
passés par cette armée se passer
c'est pas désolé c'est pas une pensée
doté qu'il faut passer les flocons son
bâton dans trente secondes en réponse
des autorités concernées il est
difficile de prévenir ce genre de
situation toutes les équipes de la d2
d'île de france près d'un millier
d'hommes étaient sur le pont dès hier
après-midi un présalage avant les chutes
de neige à délaisser effectués mais il
n'a pas suffi la prévention ça
fonctionne jusqu'à une certaine
épaisseur de neige
mais au delà il faut enlever la neige il
faut la raclée sur le côté il faut la
levée il n'y a pas d'autre moyen que
celui ci malheureusement pour l'enlever
il faut pouvoir passer
or en région parisienne comme dans
toutes les grandes agglomérations
françaises et bien qu'à tourner à
l'addition du trafic et de l'événement
neigeux et vienne on n'arrive plus
intervenir au fil de la journée tout est
rentré dans l'ordre
la neige a fondu les des milliers
d'automobilistes ne sont pas prêts
d'oublier cette nuit blanche un peu
particulière progression du trafic
voyageurs de la sncf en 98 plus de 4 4 %
tous réseaux confondus c'est la
croissance la plus forte depuis 10 ans
pour les cncf mais les résultats
financiers eux sont moins agréables sncf
enregistrera très probablement selon son
président louis gallois
une perte nette supérieure aux 500
millions de francs soit un peu plus de
76 millions d'euros pour 98 l'accord sur
la réduction du temps de travail et edf
gdf été saluée comme exemplaire par les
ministres strauss kahn et aubry
mais l udf pierre méhaignerie s'est dit
scandalisé par cet accord qui fait
l'objet d'une aide financière de l'état
de 600 millions de francs
symboliquement les 35 heures à edf et
air france relance la politique
gouvernementale en la matière
commentaires jean paul chapu
cela ressemble au décollage des 35
heures en tout cas les entreprises
publiques mettent le turbo sur la
réduction du temps de travail
la air france 4000 emplois seront créés
en trois ans grâce à l'accord conclu ce
week-end pour l'ensemble du personnel au
sol à et des fdf
l'accord intervenu hier soir concerne
140 mille salariés et va permettre de
créer au moins 3000 emplois en trois ans
même la cgt devrait signer marquant
ainsi un changement de cap
la fin de l'opposition systématique la
stratégie du non a priori je crois c'est
peut-être ça qui nous a un peu un peu
gêné dans le passé mais c'est pas vrai
seulement pour élèves c'est vraiment une
démarche sur laquelle nous avons et nous
continuerons de beaucoup discuter faire
discuter faire réfléchir pour aider f
gdf l'état a fait un gros effort
financier 550 millions de francs
là encore c'est une première du coup la
réduction du temps de travail reprend
des couleurs
la loi aubry n'avait créé ou sauvé que
10000 emplois essentiellement dans le
textile le sucre et la métallurgie un
bilan peu flatteur pour une mesure clé
du programme socialiste
c'est compliqué de réduire la durée du
travail nous l'avons tous dit il faut
réfléchir à l'organisation du travail à
l'utilisation des machines à une
meilleure articulation entre la vie
familiale et professionnelle des
salariés
donc ce sont les petites entreprises qui
ont signé les premières mais vous allez
voir que nous allons voir arriver dans
les jours qui viennent des grandes
entreprises avant la fin de cette année
martine aubry présentera à l'assemblée
une deuxième loi sur les 35 heures elle
fixera les modalités définitives smic
heures supplémentaires travail des
cadres les chefs d'entreprise
préférerait dissiper plus tôt ces
incertitudes
mais le gouvernement ne souhaite pas
accélérer le calendrier rentrée
politique de robert hue pour ce début
d'année 99 le secrétaire national du
parti communiste présente ses voeux et
écarte définitivement l'idée d'une liste
commune de la gauche plurielle aux
élections européennes commentaires
françoise david avec claude dernier
robert hue à son air déterminé des
grands jours il a un message important à
faire face à lionel jospin
les français qui selon lui attendait
beaucoup de la gauche au pouvoir
commencerait à douter les changements
réels qu'ils espéraient ne serait pas au
rendez-vous s'agit pas de s'énerver il
s'agit d'être efficace offensif dynamite
je crois qu'il ne faut pas transformer
ses attentes en scepticisme voire en
opposition il faut apporter les réponses
cela qu'attendent les françaises et les
français
le parti communiste souhaite donc par
exemple que l'on investisse pour
l'emploi et non à la bourse que l'on
cesse de privatiser et surtout que le
gouvernement ne cède pas ce qu'il
appelle les pressions libéral autant de
thèmes que de pc défendra au cours de la
campagne pour les élections européennes
une campagne qui mènera seule l'idée
d'une liste commune de la gauche
plurielle étant totalement écartée place
du colonel fabien dans leur musette les
candidats estampillés communiste
rouvrons la nouvelle doctrine de leur
parti cela s'appelle communisme un
nouveau projet et c'est signé robert e
et puis le président de l'assemblée
nationale monsieur laurent fabius en
présentant ses voeux pour la nouvelle
année a indiqué qu'il prendrait du recul
en février pendant le procès devant la
cour de justice de la république où il
doit comparaître dans l' affaire du sang
contaminé au kosovo libération effective
s'est faite des huit soldats serbes
yougoslave qui était détenu par les
séparatistes kosovars de lui ses caves
si la libération de ce soldat la
négociation avait été nommé par l'ouest
et à l'organisation pour la sécurité et
la coopération en europe en irak nouvel
incident militaire entre les irakiens
les avions américains s'est semble-t-il
50e incidents depuis la fin de
l'opération renard du désert
le 19 décembre dernier on craint dans la
perspective de la fin du ramadan la
semaine prochaine une reprise des
affrontements ou des bombardements
d'autre part la france soutenue par le
secrétaire général de l'onu monsieur
kofi annan a présenté ses propositions à
ses partenaires du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu concernant l'irak commentaires
philippe rochon
des f-15 et f-16 comme ceux ci en
patrouille au-dessus du nord de l'irak
accroché par un radar qui évite avec un
leurre un missile sol-air irakien puis
l'arc deux bombes téléguidées sur le
site
ce genre d'incident est à présent
quotidien il s'est produit ce matin dans
la zone d'exclusion aérienne à hauteur
de la ville de mossoul
il intervient au moment où la france
présentait son plan pour l'irak au
conseil de sécurité
après l'avoir évoquée hier à moscou dans
une rencontre entre hubert védrine et
evgueni primakov un plan qui prévoit
déjà la presse comme la commission de
contrôle de l'onu n'est plus crédible
la france propose donc un nouveau
dispositif de surveillance et
d'inspection en irak afin d'empêcher de
nouveaux le développement d'armes de
destruction massive la france préconise
aussi la levée de l'embargo sur les
exportations de pétrole irakien
un embargo toujours très contrôlés dans
le golfe comme ici par les britanniques
la mission de ce porte hélicoptères et
de vérifier la provenance des navires
car les américains et les anglais eux ne
sont pas prêts à mettre fin à cet
embargo contre l'irak
saddam hussein voit pourtant avec
satisfaction le conseil de sécurité se
diviser sur le sort de son pays
il soufflait ce matin le chaud et le
froid parlant de dialogue mais demandons
aussi au reste du monde arabe de
condamner l'action des britanniques et
des américains à la maison blanche à
washington le président bill clinton a
tenu une conférence de presse ses
avocats ont présenté aux sénateurs un
document de 130 pages exposant la ligne
de défense du chef de l'état américain
celui ci croit que le scénar rejettera
sa destitution il est conforté par les
sondages six américains sur dix
l'approuvent
bill clinton et sa politique à paris
première journée d'un congrès
d'allergologie un millier de
spécialistes sont réunis de plus en plus
d'enfants et d'adultes souffrent
d'allergies de nouvelles formes
d'allergies sont constatés en voici une
illustré par l'exemple
l'allergie oblates les blacks qui
envahissent les appartements reportage
sébastien leguay claude barny
depuis sept ans nathanaël est suivi pour
une allergie une affection moins banal
que celles dues au pollen ou eau
poussière de maison
ses ennemis déclarés ce sont les blattes
et mener mais non on ne naît pas boucher
va déterminer pas à m'envoyer en corde
et attend votre important non pas du
tout non même dans la cuisine jean alesi
encore une fois ça 110 aujourd'hui il
est encore asthmatiques
mais pour limiter au maximum les risques
l'hôpital n'a pas lésiné sur les moyens
on a collaboré avec le service d'hygiène
de la ville de strasbourg pour faire une
éradication complète des blattes dans le
mobilier qui existait dans l'ancien
appartement et de désinsectiser
préventivement le nouvel appartement
dans lesquelles ils ont déménagé
désinsectiser c'était le meilleur
traitement pour nathanaël car les
blattes comme les acariens les poils de
chat les poils de chiens peuvent
provoquer de l'asthme faire couler
l'aîné et rougir les yeux encore faut-il
bien les identifier
alors là il s'agit de blattes
orientaliste qui est effectivement un
peu impressionnante et pas très
attrayante mais heureusement elle est
rare on la trouve dans les caves et les
peu allergisants tu là nous avons relaté
l'un germanica qui est beaucoup plus
petit et qu'on va retrouver en france
dans nos pays dans nos eaux dans les
appartements c'est elle qui est
responsable la grande majorité des
allergies à la plate c'est elle que
redoutent maternelle
aujourd'hui les tests restent positifs
et il n'est pas à l'abri de nouvelles
crises d'asthme quand le samu ils vont
me soit aussi jeune
je restais toujours aux urgences c'était
il ya un pas qu'on me dise dans le
langage médical y avait un vide
respiratoires n'entendez pas du tout ma
respiration c'est du passé mais la
surveillance continue dans l'appartement
où a été relogé la famille de nathanaël
martin oates vient prélever tous les
mois des échantillons de poussière elles
traquent la blatte et donne des conseils
pour s'en prémunir
l'idéal c'est de pouvoir se couper du
reste de l'immeuble ce qui est parfois
difficile ce qui a toujours des
tuyauteries des chauffages débit
d'ordures des choses communes donc ce
qu'il faudrait essayer de boucher le
maximum ces ouvertures là et d'avoir des
traitements efficaces
nathanaël et sa famille peuvent respirer
les analyses montrent que les blattes ne
les ont pas retrouvé la stratégie a
fonctionné mais il est difficile de la
mettre en oeuvre à grande échelle car
ces intrus s'invite de plus en plus dans
nos appartements selon le secrétariat
d'état à la santé la pollution par le
plomb a diminué de 50 % en 20 ans mais
les risques de saturnisme sont encore
bien présents et prochainement un décret
sera publié
obligeant à réaliser des travaux de mise
en conformité dans un délai d'un mois
pour des appartements dans les peintures
contiennent du plomb sport championnats
du monde de snowboard du surf des neiges
en allemagne à versus gadahn médaille
d'argent pour le français maxence idée
chan en slalom géant 1re place dans ce
fameux géant pour l'allemand marcus
hellner
voilà l'arrivée du français médaille
d'argent automobile le dakar la 12e
étape disputée en mauritanie entre mes
mains et tichit sur la distance 490 km
regardez-bien victoire d'étape au tour
de jean louis schlesser devant prieto
sur mitsubishi meyboom c'est comme sur
ma chère villeneuve on se fait pas de
cadeaux même en plein désert pour
arriver de la place jean michel serres
sur son buggy est toujours en tête au
classement général
théâtre depuis hier soir à paris au
théâtre du rond point on joue une
nouvelle pièce de jean-claude grumberg
rêvait peut-être avec dans le rôle-titre
pierre arditi candy qui interprète un
homme hanté par ses rêves et par le
souvenir de ses parents nouveaux
personnages nouveaux défis pour 1,46 à
l'emploi de l'emploi du temps déjà très
chargé le reportage laurence piquet
bernard puissesseau et bernhard kohl
heures une promenade dans les passages
de paris pierre arditi mc lieu de
vagabondage les bruits de la ville le
rassure avant d'entrer sur scène je
viens chercher des moments de paix me
promener à pied dans paris c'est ce que
je préfère et le trac ça s'apaise avec
les années non avec les années ça
s'aggrave
tout ça ça s'appelle pas du tout parce
que il ya 20 ans finalement personne ne
savait trop qui j'étais bon maintenant
les gens quand même ça va un petit suis
donc ils attendent de moi un certain
nombre de choses
donc j'ai évidemment beaucoup plus peur
moi je me concentre en balade à
répétition avec le metteur en scène jean
michel ribes
la pièce se déroule la nuit dans nos
rêves pierre arditi court après l'image
de sa mère maman oui je peux dormir dans
son lit pourquoi on finit à la maison
des fleurs dans les cheveux région de
l'ironie et de la gravité
le héros est hanté par le souvenir de
son père déporté cauchemar vécu par
l'auteur de la pièce un jean claude
grumberg
d'en rêver peut-être l'inconscient se
libère il nous rappelle à tous à
l'importance du rôle du père et de la
mère
moi aussi j'ai des rêves de pair moi mon
père il est là je n'ai pas enfouie sous
du papier à fleurs il est vivant il est
âgé mini vivant il ya ma mère aussi qu'
elle n'est plus là mais à qui je parle
absolument tous les jours y a pas de
jour je ne parle pas ma mère où je me
lève pas en disant bonjour ma mère on
pense à ma mère en regardant son visage
sur les toiles peintes par mon père moi
je crois que quand on est un père ou
mère dans l'instant on devient père ou
mère le poids compte qu'on fait porter à
l'enfant qu'il vous est arrivé jusqu'à
mon dernier souffle
le poids de mon père vivant le poids de
ma mère morte mais entre ou jusqu'à la
fin de mes jours
chaque fois quelque chose nous avons
entre les bras d'une mère pourquoi ça me
coucher tous les deux dans mon lit et la
présence insolite d'un avocat doit
surveiller vos rêves interprété par
michel aumont
j'ai perdu moche et pierre arditi
cherchera à soigner les blessures de
l'enfance d'arriver à la fin de ce
journal je rappelle deux informations
nous avons développé crise boursière
tout d'abord notamment sur place
européenne le ça semble aller mieux à
wall street ce soir à washington
les poussières la suite de la
dévaluation de la monnaie brésilienne et
l'effondrement de l'économie
et puis crise politique européenne la
première grande crise politique
européenne avec peut-être un sursis pour
la commission européenne les membres des
groupes politiques du parlement européen
sont actuellement réunis pour en
débattre avant d'un vote de censure
demain à strasbourg
dans quelques secondes la météo d'isabel
martinez 20h50 un téléfilm la balle au
bond
williams crépin et notamment isabelle
otero à 22h50
ça se discute présentée par jean-luc
delarue le dernier journal vous sera
présentée par laurence ostolaza à zéro
heure 55 suivi du bivouac et du cercle
de philippe lefait demain 7h50
françoise laborde recevra le député udf
jacques barrot et puis à 13h vous
trouverez carole gaessler et rachid
arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci